We don't have time for this. We gotta get...
Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is going to be my mandalorian season 2 episode 6 video there
was so much stuff that happened so many easter
eggs and references going all the way back to
the prequel movies so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
we're doing a disney plus membership giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and post your favorite easter egg from the episode
on the video careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet obviously because there's so
much to talk about i'm gonna number this a little
bit differently just starting at the beginning
of the episode the title of the episode is the
tragedy referencing mando losing grogu to moff
gideon and losing the razor crest when i first
saw the title of the episode i actually wondered
which tragedy they were trying to reference from
the canon because there are so many tragedies
in star wars that you could point to there's
order 66 there's emperor palpatine going on about
darth plagueis cue up the clip have ever told you
about the tragedy of darth plagueis the wise the
episode was directed by robert rodriguez of all
people he was actually probably one of the biggest
names that they got to direct episodes this season
it's the shortest episode of season two so far as
well it's just a little over 30 minutes long and a
lot of people when they heard this earlier this
week thought that it would be a filler episode
but it totally was not a filler episode at all
i think one of the reasons why they had robert
rodriguez direct this episode is because it was so
action heavy and because he's so good at working
on low budgets most of the movies he works on
are relatively low budget compared to traditional
big big action movies we got so many cool reveals
and references to the prequel movies with boba
fett and jango fett they explained how they're
connected to the mandalorians historically and
the true origin of boba fett's green beskar armor
which is a bit of a retcon because originally his
armor was supposed to be dura steel and not only
did they bring temuera morrison back as boba fett
and he actually spoke he had dialogue as boba fett
they also brought ming knob back from season one
as well sort of answering what happened after
that episode five post-credits scene i felt like
most of people's theories were correct because
we did think that that was boba fett coming to
her body but we just didn't know what he was doing
when he came to her body the episode starts with
mando taking grogu to the planet tython i did a
video a while ago about the history and the lore
surrounding this planet this is them going back to
the true origins of the jedi originally the order
that preceded the jedi order that we think of
when we think of the jedi order like yoda obi-wan
kenobi anakin skywalker luke skywalker belonged to
the jedi order the order that preceded that more
than 25 000 years ago was the jedi it's spelled a
little bit differently they actually studied three
different schools of the force the light the dark
and the balance between them the ashla the bogan
and the bendu if you remember the bendu from star
wars rebels which is sort of like a lion turtle
in the star wars universe for all you avatar
the last airbender fans dave filoni obviously
the showrunner from rebels also worked on avatar
the last airbender the original avatar the last
airbender series so the bendu was sort of like his
version of a lion turtle in the star wars canon
but the whole idea with those original force
practitioners is that they practice both the light
sides and the dark sides of the force making them
a little bit more powerful than you would think a
traditional jedi or traditional sith or dark side
force user would be but they follow up the scene
with mando playing with the control knob getting
grogo to use the force a couple more times they
played for a little bit of comedy with him saying
grogo's name out loud and grogu just responds a
little more quickly and because ahsoka tano told
him about all the jedi training that he received
he knows he's much more learned he speaks to him
more like an adult now than a tiny little kid
he uses that weird curse word again dank ferric
he's used that several times in the series and
they've never really told us exactly what it means
but it's sort of like the star wars version of
dropping an f-bomb they start playing some sad
music when mando starts talking to grogu about
eventually having to part ways look kid you're
gonna have to stay with these jedi they're gonna
teach you i don't know enough to teach you you're
way too powerful for that he hilariously refers to
ahsoka tano as the nice lady the special rock
that he's taking grogu to this very powerful
in the force actually looks like a natural
focusing array just built out of the landscape
meant to focus all the force energy of the planet
they have a bit of a funny moment with mando just
trying to figure out how to turn it on and get him
to do what he's supposed to do but he turns around
a couple times and when he comes back grogu has
gone full master yoda meditating in the force and
there's this giant beam of force energy projecting
out into the galaxy so you have to remember that
this is a beacon that's reaching out to the entire
galaxy which is enormous so that is how powerful
it is and that's why mando isn't able to penetrate
it when he tries to go grab grogu through it a
couple different times he tries three different
times in the episode but just as he begins boba
fett's slave one ship enters in the background
and obviously if you've even seen a little bit
of star wars you instantly know that that's his
ship so i love the way they play the tension
in the early part of the episode because boba
fett has typically been portrayed as a villain
even though technically he's not a villain he's
really just a bounty hunter so he's true neutral
he's neither bad nor good and they actually kind
of hold true to that during the episode he tells
mando that he's been tracking him this whole
time and they have a gunslinger standoff moment
he's only there for his armor though he doesn't
even react when mando starts referencing the
child are you here for the kid it's totally weird
hearing temuera morrison speak without the helmet
on now if you've gone back and you've watched the
star wars movies probably a billion times they've
actually retconned his voice into boba fett in
empire strikes back so you've actually heard
him speak as boba fett a couple times before but
never with the mask off and he just looks raw from
being in the sarlacc pit he references jango fett
saying that it belonged to his father before him
it takes a while during the episode for them to
get across that hump eventually mando does come
around on it there's a really cool reference
to the three-way gunslinger standoff from the
good the bad and the ugly they've parried it on a
billion other television shows so if you've ever
seen a reference to a three-way mexican standoff
that's what it's referencing but you have fenik
shan who steps in and says oh good to see you
again mando it reveals that boba fett rescued
her and that's why she's in his service now she
doesn't seem upset about it she just seems like
she's happy to be alive and it's really only been
about a year since that episode so she hasn't been
working with boba fett for that long but then she
reveals that she's gone full darth vader with a
whole bunch of cybernetic parts to keep her alive
when mando questions him about taking the creed
the code of the mandalorians even the hardcore
mandalorians from death watch that mando comes
from boba fett says he swears allegiance to no
one but himself then he says sometimes fate steps
in to rescue the wretched obviously he's talking
about fenix shan because he stepped in to rescue
her but he also says that he was left on the sands
of tatooine to die as well referencing the sarlacc
pit from return of the jedi now he doesn't explain
exactly how he escaped i talked a little bit about
this during episode 1 when they revealed that he
had survived in the first place there was this
whole backstory they gave us during the episode
about how the krait dragons are the natural
predators of the sarlaccs around tatooine so it's
likely that the krait dragon that they killed had
previously killed the sarlacc that had eaten boba
fett and the chaos of that allowed him to escape
they set up the big twist for the end of the
episode with boba fett teaming up with mando
when he says he'll guarantee his and grogu safety
in exchange for his family's armor fenix shand
also reminds mando that the bounty on grogu has
risen significantly since season one so i was
kind of expecting an even bigger twist with boba
fett's character he was surprisingly honorable in
the episode from what my expectations were but
then when you see everyone's reactions when the
stormtroopers show up you actually get a lot
of answers about what's really going on with
boba fett no he actually really is here just to
get his armor he's not working with mob gideon
these ships they're traveling in are just standard
imperial troop transports from the imperial era of
the original trilogy of movies as mando tries
and fails to go back and grab grogu through the
force barrier a couple more times and fails each
time just getting repelled boba fett and phoenix
shan start taking out the stormtroopers one by
one they give him each a couple really badass
moments so you get to see boba fett without
his armor using the gaffy stick from episode
one that's the tool that the tuscan raiders use to
clean the bantha's teeth but it's also used as a
weapon as well a very good weapon at that he uses
to smash the stormtrooper's armor pretty easily i
love the way it dashes too i don't think we've
seen scenes like this in star wars before it's
just a way to show you how badass boba fett is
even though this is a much older version of boba
fett who's not wearing his armor so he doesn't
have any of his traditional tools or weapons
temuera morrison did a great job with the action
scenes it feels like he did a lot of this himself
too and later when it was him in the armor it was
actually him wearing the armor not a stunt person
i love the way they foreshadowed during the
episode too because after he takes out a couple
of them he's near the razor crest and you see
the doors open and you know exactly what's going
to happen next they cut away to fenix shan to give
her some creative kills but just as mando comes to
team up with her and starts shielding her with his
best car armor you get the big boba fett reveal as
he jet packs in in his armor and quickly takes
out all the other stormtroopers with a bunch of
different weapons that he has all over his armor
so is them sort of fulfilling on the promise that
we were given during the original trilogy when we
were all younger watching these movies seeing boba
fett and him being hyped up is this super badass
bounty hunter but never really seeing him get that
many badass scenes so sort of them redeeming his
character after being taken out so hilariously in
return of the jedi then of course we were all just
waiting for him to use that rocket launcher so
of course the stormtroopers take off in the drop
ships again to go back to the cruiser but he uses
the rocket launcher and takes them both out two
with one shot i love that funny reveal too when
mando compliments him like oh that was amazing and
he says oh i was actually aiming for the other one
then as they've done several times this season
they sort of take back that awesome moment
yank the rug out from under us by blowing up the
razor crest moff gideon lands an instant hit but
everybody press f in the chat to pay respects to
the razor crest are you now kind of wondering what
they're gonna do for his ship during season three
when we get to that because they've been selling
the razor crest as a toy so either they're gonna
give him a brand new ship or a brand new version
of the razer crest i don't know how they're
gonna do that though because that thing was blown
to atoms like there's almost nothing of it that's
left it's also kind of hilarious that as mando
rushes back to try and grab grogu the beacon's
still up so he can't penetrate the barrier again
but just as he runs off the barrier lowers like
just as he turns away boom he's done and despite
the way the episode ended you have to remember
that grogu was successful in communicating to the
rest of the galaxy reaching out to anyone who's
powerful enough in the force to detect his signal
mission accomplished so literally anyone good
or bad jedi sith dark force users even the night
sisters who are relatively powerful in the force
anyone who could detect this signal could wind up
showing up by the season finale or in season 3 in
future seasons it's a way for them to introduce a
whole bunch of new characters potentially in the
future because it's no one character that's going
to show up a number of different people probably
detected that beacon in the force and will show up
over the course of a couple seasons and everyone's
pulling for sam jackson to show up as mace windu
or sebastian stan as a new version of luke
skywalker there are so many different jedi that
could show up from legends canon even mara jade
of all people could show up as well if they're
pulling so many characters from deep cuts and we
know the grand admiral thrawn is coming soon too
visually the dark troopers look like a cross
between the phase one and the phase two dark
troopers from the dark forces video game if
you've never played that it's one of the most
amazing original 90s star wars games it's a super
deep cut but just explaining what they are because
they do kind of look like droids they're basically
droid human hybrids it's basically like organic
parts from all the cloning experiments that we've
seen moff gideon doing combined with droid bodies
just to make them super soldiers so to speak and
remember they just grabbed grogu and took off we
haven't actually seen them for real in action yet
which would probably be something for the finale
mando picks through the bones of what's left of
the razor crest and fishes the best scar spear out
which is obviously unharmed because it's vescar
and grogu's little toy that he was playing with
the control knob from the razor crest then
they sort of continued that idea this boba
fett redemption that they've been doing through
the mandalorian series when he says that he's
going to help mando out because their deal is
not complete you said that you give the armor
back and in exchange we would keep you and grosgu
safe and he's not safe yet so they're going to
help him take grogu back from moff gideon look at
boba fett being all honorable i was so surprised
by this twist in the episode i was not expecting
this at all then as boba fett notices the best car
spear he shows mando his personal chain code
identifier embedded in the green beskar armor
it's like an id stamp with the family history
written in mandalorian code telling mando he
really is boba fett and showing him the identifier
for his father jango fett and mando sees that it
identifies jango fett as a foundling just like
him saying that he fought in the mandalorian
civil wars so boba fett flies them back to navarro
in the slave 1 so that they can get cara dunes
help because mando wants to break bill burr's
character from season 1 out of prison because
he's a former imperial sharpshooter to help them
track down moff gideon's cruiser but then probably
one of the best scenes from the episode most wtf
scenes as well is we go back to moff gideon's
cruiser as it's traveling through hyperspace and
as he's traveling through the hallway i love the
way that they reveal this too it's kind of a slow
reveal because you hear stormtroopers groaning
and screaming in the background and when they
reveal what's happening you see grogu going full
darth vader choking them crushing their throats
throwing them all over the ship using the force
he is pissed off but even better moff gideon seems
so happy about this he just seems so pleased with
himself watching grogu fall to the dark side like
he kind of wants this he even stops his other
stormtroopers from intervening and stopping grogu
like no no no let him wear himself out killing
these other men of ours it's also a clever way to
remind you that moff gideon doesn't really care
about any of his underlings they're really just
tools for him to use then after grogu finishes
smashing the hell out of the stormtroopers
he collapses in exhaustion and moff gideon
starts taunting him with the darksaber he asks
if he remembers the lightsabers of the jedi
that he trained with the jedi temple the jedi
masters on coruscant grogu tries to reach out
with the force to steal it from him to snatch
the darksaber from his hand but he's too tired
moff guinea actually makes a really clever
reference that seems kind of like foreshadowing
he says you might wind up putting someone's eye
out you're not ready to play with such things
so when i say foreshadowing it just feels like
they're going to pay that off either in the finale
or in a future episode where grogu really does
wind up taking moff gideon's eye out or someone
else's eye out with the dark saber they take grogo
out with the same stun gun that they took princess
leia out with in a new hope because this whole
prison scene with grogu is meant to reference the
scene of darth vader interrogating princess leia
on the death star remember moff gideon's character
is sort of designed visually to reference darth
vader he wears the same black space cape same
black armor he wields a lightsaber just like
darth vader slightly different kind of lightsaber
but the darksaber is still a lightsaber and even
though the way they leave him there all passed out
is meant to be this really wtf ending cliffhanger
to the episode i laughed a little bit when he said
shackle him and they put the tiniest little
shackles on him that you've ever seen in your
entire life if you keep watching the end credits
though with all the concept art it always looks
fantastic i always love the concept art for
each of the episodes but you actually notice
that they have some really cool interior shots
of the slave one if you haven't seen it before
but if you spotted any really big easter eggs
or references during the episode that i didn't
mention during the video just write them below
in the comments and what will happen is i'll do
a couple more bonus videos this week for some of
the bigger easter eggs leave all your requests in
the comments too and obviously my mandalorian
season 2 episode 7 video will post next friday
just like normal while you wait for everything
click here to learn about all the jedi and sith
characters who survived order 66 and could show
up to answer grogu's call in the force on the
mandalorian series and click here for my full
mandalorian season 2 episode 5 ahsoka tano video
thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe this is the way!